wait what if I'm writing songs that that
prompts you say like ringing up Nancy
and say Jordy here song like that must
be the nicest feeling in the world
having someone particularly poorly
currently like write you a song because
you have used lots of names you know
there's a shell and owner Jude Lizzy
Sadie and I guess some names are better
for songs not hmm we've got three
creative minds on the sofa all
songwriters I don't know what you say Oh
does anyone in the audience think they
have a name that they can't think of a
rhyme for obviously everything the
audience has a name lady putting her
hand up name you think oh that was a
little lady over there in the corner can
we get the boom all the way what what's
your name Jimmy so she should me so yeah
do you want to share a me so you should
be so yeah you should be so lucky to
come with me and share a Mesa
[Applause]
anyone anyone else anyone else there's a
lady a lady there with her hand up by
the wall wore number bit of a bomber the
problem and dumber
oh yeah yeah gone during summer we would
listen to Joe Strummer but I had to
leave her because she wouldn't let me
bummer
[Applause]
you can write some of these ideas me and
Katy Perry bummer
okay one last one I said well and so on
there's a lady there with a short or
actually don't let's do the bitchery
lady lorna jean no let's not do that
so they go through all their oh oh it's
a good one
what what is it ulla ulla Finland from
Finland Loula come on James come on come
on guys I couldn't fool ah oh you
couldn't fool her because she's cooler
than a plastic ruler
[Applause]
it's it's not quite an action figure but
it's
[Applause]
[Laughter]